en 1917
einstein compris que ces équations de la
relativité générale prédisaient une fin
des temps ne pouvait pas l'accepter
il s'empresse alors de réexaminer sa
théorie et la bloody fia cette
modification fut en ces termes la plus
grosse bêtise de sa vie mais était ce
vraiment une bêtise jeu reviendra dans
une minute pour commencer laisse moi
vous expliquer pourquoi einstein a
décidé de modifier ses équations la
matière partout dans l'univers
contribuer à courber positif dans tout
l'espace temps qui la contient
et ça ça veut dire que les trajectoires
de la matière ne peuvent pas rester
indéfiniment parallèle intuitivement
elle devrait finir par se concentrer en
un point
annonçant une fin spectaculaire de notre
espace temps que l'on appelle parfois le
big crunch einstein ne pouvait pas
l'accepter
les rejeter l'idée d'une fin du monde
pour lui et l'univers devait être
statique éternelle du coup au lieu de
faire confiance à sa toute nouvelle
théorie de l'espace-temps einstein nuit
d'ordi le coup en ajoutant un terme de
courbure négative qu'il appelait la
constante cosmologique ça c'est déjà
étrange surtout venant d'einstein
mais il ya pire
1920 que alexander friedman soumis un
article un journal à comité de lecture
avec une solution aux équations originel
de la relativité générale
friedman supposa que l'univers était
homogène et isotrope à grande échelle
mais qu'il n'était pas statique la
taille de l'univers avait ainsi une
dynamique à travers le temps que l'on
appelle le facteur d'échelle après de
longs calculs savants friedman trouva
les équations qui détermine la destinée
de l'univers la prédiction de friedman
dépendait de la courbure cas de laisse
pas supposer homogène cet espace pouvait
être spiric comme celui de l'épisode 11
plat comme dans l'épisode 9 ou hyper
bolik comme dans l'épisode 12
dans tous les cas friedman prédit que
l'univers courait à sa perte et que
celle ci pouvait prendre la forme d'un
big crunch si l'espace était super rich
ou d'une expansion ralenti mais infini
dans les autres cas que l'on appelle le
picture
quoi qu'il en soit en tant que membre du
comité de lecture
einstein que extrêmement critique le
rejeta l'article de friedman en
affirmant que son contenu était erroné
il aura fallu près d'un an et de
nombreuses lettres pour qu'einstein se
rendent compte que ces critiques
n'étaient pas fondées einstein finit pas
rétracté ses critiques s'excuser et
reconnaître publiquement la validité
mathématiques des solutions de friedman
toutefois ces notes privé montre qu'il
ne reconnaissait pas la validité
physique
la position de friedman est tout aussi
surprenante il affirmé que ces équations
n'avait pour but que de donner une
meilleure compréhension des
mathématiques de la relativité générale
des équations d'einstein et qu'en tout
cas ces solutions n'avait absolument
rien à voir avec une réalité physique
ouais c'est un bon mathématicien
heureusement vint ensuite la baie le m
la spécificité de georges lemaître était
d'être à la fois un prêtre et un
physicien de premier rang en 1927
en étudiant le décalage vers le rouge
des galaxies lointaines il conclut que
l'univers était en expansion mieux en
remontant le temps et en combinant des
arguments de la mécanique quantique de
la thermodynamique et de la relativité
générale le maître suggéra que l'univers
tout entier était issu d'un petit coin
tonnes d'énergie
au passage lemaitre redécouvrir les
solutions cosmologique de friedman
cependant cette fois le maître argot à
que ces solutions s'appliquer à notre
propre univers
la compréhension que le maître avait de
la physique était incroyable
rebondissement que ses convictions
religieuses l'ont aidé à affirmer ce que
einstein je ne sais pas trop quoi en
penser les mathématiques de lemaître
était vraiment solide
néanmoins son hôte à cause de leurs
croyances philosophiques les physiciens
contemporain de lemaître rejeté en bloc
les ide le net
toutefois petit à petit les idées de
lemaître gagné en popularité
einstein en vain même enfin reconnaître
publiquement qu'il n'aurait jamais dû
rajouter une constante cosmologique
juste pour que sa théorie s'accordent
avec ses croyances philosophiques il
reconnu qu ajouter cette constante
cosmologique était la plus grosse bêtise
l'us albi mais était ce une bêtise d'un
côté on peut voir ça comme juste une
façon d'aligner sa théorie avec le
consensus dominant de la communauté
scientifique
quant à la destinée de l'univers et d'un
autre côté on peut voir la bêtise de
nstein com une caractérisation de
l'ensemble de toutes les équations qu
raisonnable d'une théorie de la
relativité générale très rapidement sous
entend par là c'est que les combinaisons
linéaire du thon third and chain et on
sort métriques sont les seuls temps
soeur de valence 2 feuilles de dérivés
opus 2d du tenseur métriques à être de
quadri divergences nu je sais ça fait
beaucoup de gros mots je vous promets
que ça ça correspond un très joli
théorème mathématique
quoi qu'il en soit c'est parce que
l'équation modifié d'einstein reste très
raisonnable que les physiciens se sont
jetés dessus suite à des découvertes
observationnelles récente en 1998 suite
à des analyses de décalage vers le rouge
de queyrac si très lointaines des
physiciens ont découvert que non
seulement l'univers est en expansion
mais cette expansion de l'univers est en
fait en train de s'accélérer dans un
futur très lointain
l'expansion de l'univers sera si rapide
que toutes les autres galaxies
s'éloigneront de nous à une vitesse
supérieure à celle de la lumière et
sortiront ainsi de notre univers
observable nos descendants vent alors
l'impression de vivre dans la seule et
unique galaxies de l'univers en fait
plutôt que vers un big crunch où un big
chill l'univers semble voué à mourir en
big rip dans un futur où les galaxies
les systèmes solaires les planètes voire
même les atomes finiront par s'isoler
spatialement voilà qui est clairement un
consistant avec l'équation original
einstein qui suggère que l'expansion de
l'univers devrait au moins ralentir
comme je le dis dans une vidéo
précédente ceci est une anomalie qui
réfute l'équation originale de la
relativité générale d'einstein cependant
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
ceci est aussi étonnamment consistant
avec l'équation modifié d'einstein celle
dont il dit
l quelle était sa plus grosse bêtise les
physiciens ont depuis donné un nom à la
cause de l'expansion accélérée de
l'univers la belle énergie sombre
énergie nous c'est la même chose mais il
ne s'agit là que d'un nom pour faire
référence à quelque chose que l'on ne
comprend absolument pas de manière
fondamentale en fait la nature de
l'énergie sombre et l'un des plus grands
mystères de la physique moderne et des
tentatives de l'expliquer via la
physique quantique ont échoué
lamentablement
david sur son étonnante appelle même ses
tentatives
la plus grosse erreur de production de
toute l'histoire des sciences
ironiquement l'explication la plus
avancée aujourd'hui est celle donnée par
einstein et sa constante cosmologique
un demi-siècle après qu'il a
honteusement retirer quelques décennies
après l'avoir honteusement rajouter
l'étrangement les physiciens
d'aujourd'hui affirme que la plus grosse
bêtise de nstein n'était en fait pas une
la dernière fois je vous ai narrer la
découverte de la relativité générale
d'einstein et j'avais pas mal parlé de
l'expérience de des clips sont vous
disant notamment que le rayon de la
lumière n'était pas dévié dans la
théorie de newton et guillermo gourde il
m'a fait la remarque très juste que
selon richard taille est si en fait
certains théoriciens de l'époque penser
qu'en effet la lumière serait quand même
dévié par une masse même si la lumière
n'a pas de masse est en effet en arrive
là dans une zone d'ombré de la théorie
newtonienne puisque newton pensait que
la lumière avait une base qui pensait
pas que il fallait gérer des fruits qui
avait pas de masse et du coup il avait
écrit son équation de la gravité que
pour des objets qui avait une masse
cependant il ya deux façons
d'interpréter la théorie newtonienne
soit on se dit que les forces n'affecte
que les objets qui ont une masse ou soit
on interprète la gravité comme un chant
de pesanteur c'est à dire un peu
l'analogie de la toile se dire qu'on va
essayer de descendre cette toile donc un
terme maintenant ça veut dire avoir une
accélération qui va être proportionnelle
ou gradient du champ de pesanteur et du
coup avec cette image tous les objets
suivent des signes d'accélération vers
le bas de cette toile donc en théorie
newtonienne je vous rappelle que cette
image là elle est très étonné n'est
absolument pas une espagne la lumière
devrait aussi accélérer et donc être
courbé dans son mouvement comme explique
richard taille est toutefois les
prédictions que l'on fait avec ce choix
de pesanteur ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles que einstein a fait avec la
théorie de la relativité générale et
c'est cette prédiction très précises
d'einstein qui a été confirmé par
l'observation des dictons qui a aussi au
passage rejeté aussi la théorie
newtonienne donc voilà j'ai dit une
imprécision dans la vidéo précédente
heureusement il ya des gens comme
guillermo gordy pour corriger tout ça
christophe andré critique l'image que
j'ai mis pour expliquer que la lumière
était dg dans sa trajectoire
en fait cette image à elle est
remarquablement juste bon elle est pas
belle thématiquement parfaitement juste
puisque bon j'ai fait ça avec des effets
sur un seul côté que c'est pas du tout
calculé de façon mathématique mais
l'idée est pas mal derrière cet e-mail
condition de bien interpréter l'hymne
ayant cette image c'est que je prends un
espace original qui est les plats qui va
être orthogonale à la direction ôté
direction vers le futur
ce que l'on voit à dessiner dans cette
image c'est surtout il faut imaginer que
tous points blancs ici
et en fait un vecteur qui se dirige vers
le futur si on considère les mouvements
selon à direction était en tout point de
l'espace on a les points blancs ici ses
trajectoires là si on les regarde dans
la carte classique de l'espace-temps
dont la vitrine de chantilly on va voir
quelle se courbe vers le centre du
soleil est là je tiens le rappeler on
voit ses trajectoires courbes dans notre
carte et de l'esp restant milan vrai ces
traducteurs sont des lignes droites dans
l'espace-temps ce qu'on va vraiment dans
cette image c'est que deux points qui a
été dense selon une direction à radiall
ou avoir tendance à s'éloigner du car en
dehors de l'étoile alors que deux points
qui sont séparés de manière orthographe
diane ou avoir tendance à se rapprocher
et ça ça correspond exactement aux
danseurs métriques que j'ai eus dont
j'ai parlé dans l'épisode sur les
danseurs de l'arrêté général et ça
correspond aussi très bien à l'effet des
marées
imaginez que vous remplacez la terre par
un trou noir et vous vous imaginez
quelque part très du trouve en train de
vous rapprocher du trou noir la courbure
de l'espace-temps pas vous étiez ray
dans le sens de la longueur ou de la
hauteur si vos pieds sont vers le trou
noir et va vous écrasez vous comprimé
dans la direction arthaud radial si bien
que vous allez être spaghetti fier c'est
ce qu'on appelle les spaghettis fication
et ça ça correspond également très bien
l effet des marais dont j'avais parlé de
manière nous tone yens dans l'épisode 17
et ça ça correspond à une autre analogie
que ma très justement souligné jonathan
balle à man dans un commentaire sur
facebook où il disait imaginer l'espace
comme une espèce de marc avec un espèce
de trou au milieu et puis l'eau ce
tombeau tomberait vers ce trou est un
poisson qui est vrai dans cette eau du
coup serait emporté par le courant mais
lui ce qui m'intéresse c'est juste le
mouvement de l'eau localement et lui
s'il suit l'aube à une morale ont
l'impression de rien du tout dans cette
analogie je sais pas si jonathan ya
pensé de lui même mais c'est une super
radiologie puisque c'est une jcct est
également réutiliser par leonardo sauce
kim pour parler notamment des trous
noirs tout cas c'est une analogique et
beaucoup beaucoup plus juste que
âge et leur étoile qui encore une fois
n'est que newtonienne gohan couple me
demande pourquoi est-ce que si ce qu'on
ressent sur terre la gravité comment
sont nées que l'accès à son vers le haut
du sol pourquoi est-ce que lorsqu'on
compris calcul ce sujet notamment on
voit apparaître la constante granger de
la gravitation la raison pour laquelle
c'est le cas c'est que j'allais vous
imaginer que si la terre était plus
petit que c'est qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui avec tout voir la même
quantité d'énergie
il y aura une pression beaucoup plus
grande à l'intérieur de la terre et cet
excès de pression va faire une force de
pression encore plus grand qui va faire
que l'accélération du sol vers le haut
de la terre va être plus grande qu'elle
ne l'est aujourd'hui du coup on va voir
plus grande accélération et en
particulier cette exception pourrait
être plus grande que la courbure de
l'espace-temps ce de sorte que la terre
se mette à grossir plus exactement que
sa façon de grossir à travers l'espace
temps est plus rapide que la contraction
de l'espace à travers le temps et du
coup la taille de la terre dans cette
image je ne serai plus constante est en
train de grossir et on arrivera à un
point où la terre serait tellement
grosses qu'en fait les forces de
pression diminue à l'inter de la terre
et du coup l'accélération vers le haut
de la terre diminuerait elle devrait
atteindre est peut-être même plus faible
que la contraction de l'espace donc vous
pouvez imaginer que selon ce processus
la taille de la terre oscillerait et
puis finirait par se stabiliser un point
où l'accélération vers le haut de la
terre est parfaitement compensé par la
contraction de l'espace à travers le
temps et là on attire une situation dite
livre c'est la situation dans lesquels
ont nommé aujourd'hui la taille de la
terre aujourd'hui est en équilibre
consensuelle les constantes et ça ça
veut dire que la dilatation de la terre
à cause des forces de pression à travers
l'espace est parfaitement compensé par
la contraction de l'espace à travers le
temps et c'est pour ça que l'on peut
déterminer la création vers l'eau du sol
uniquement par des calculs de relativité
générale qui se font sur la courbure de
l'espace temps et le fait que
la terre est constant enfin je reviens
sur la question de m si on met un
astronaute 200 kilomètres au dessus du
niveau du sol
est-ce qu'il va tomber sur terre à cause
de la courbure de l'espace temps
ou est-ce qu'il veut tomber sur terre à
cause de l'accélération vers le haut du
sol et le problème dans la question
c'est le monde tombait en fait c'est à
dire quoi ton mais c'est vraiment pas
évident c'est pas un concept très
physique
la question qu'on pourrait se poser
c'est pourquoi est-ce que la distance
entre l'astronaute et la surface du sol
diminue la réponse est la création vers
l'eau du sol ou l'autre question que
l'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi est-ce
que la distance entre l'astronaute et le
centre de la terre diminue et ça c'est
la courbure positif de l'espace temps je
vous rappelle ce que la vie dans
l'épisode 19 la courbure de
l'espace-temps éloigne le l'astre du sol
de la terre tu mets à approche la
surface de la terre du centre de la
terre parce que il ya de la matière a
beaucoup de matière entre les deux et
cette matière courbe l'espace-temps
positivement j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va
parler de la théorie du big bang qui si
elle est communément admise aujourd'hui
et même si le va travailler pensée a été
aux dividendes dans les années 1930 les
kanari's années 60 que les gens auront
enfin cru en cet été aurait du big bang
quiz qu'il a fallu autant de temps c'est
ce qu'on verra dans le prochain épisode
pour vous préparer vous pouvez regarder
le ciel la nuit vous demandez pourquoi
est ce que le ciel c'est une question
fait absolument passionnante
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le lichen le commenter à le partager je
vous invite à vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes
et j'espère que du beau verra la
prochaine fois alors en fait c'est aussi
d'expliquer ça avec les équations
d'einstein
à une condition de rajouter ce fameux
terme khenchla n'avait introduit et
qu'il avait fini par supprimer en disant
que c'était la plus grande erreur de
sable fin